[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want
thank you I've been practicing by the
way welcome to our show space news yeah
she was a virgin before this for helping
the girls dominate I know I'm loving
this day very rarely happens really it
happens all the time
we're killing it guys are talking we've
done that before well it's like finally
I get to relax and take a break and you
it's kind of nice it's also kind of nice
having another latina right yeah it
feels like a Latina show cuz Niki also
looks I look latina yes well she asked
banded blood I got a Spanish donk so
weird dog Spanish tonk badonkadonk dog
this booty came from Spain this is not
come from the Philippines
I kind of feel like Filipinos or is a
kind of Latina they're like that the
Mexican Asian yes but spant Spaniards
aren't counted as latina they're not no
they're Spanish but the Latinas got
[ __ ] by the span that's why I count it
in my head so everyone's a mestizos we
all got [ __ ] by the Spaniards come on
dude all of us I wish I'd be [ __ ] by
the Chinese dan the room
[Laughter]
even Bart didn't celebrate for the rest
of your statement that was it my joke I
usually do and herpes I missed you guys
hey how was your stupid forest trip
since Gio's birthday that was like oh
damn was our forest Church tio cemani
and then it was our company retreat
before I look like so much fun it was a
lot of fun everybody so [ __ ] close I
do because I wasn't there
you went it looks stupid cuz I wasn't
there it was pretty fun though with
weeks all [ __ ] rattlesnake it was in
our house you can't say fun and then say
rattlesnake in my head the retreat
that's right where was it
so it was like this huge house that like
20-something people could sleep in and
I'm old in jammu that had never heard
this [ __ ] ha walls it was a real place
next to Escondido it sounds fake you're
just saying sounds now no it's J mu mr.
mu and Escondido I thought it was Jamal
and then the fire department came and
her like all his hellos the whole fire
department oh yeah what a snake so was a
key it was almost 12:00 at night because
people wanted to kill it I'm a white
guys want to kill an animal I'm like
I'll just call my little snake we didn't
know it was a rattlesnake I also didn't
want to go to see her rattle you could
see the rattle got full sleeping Bart
couldn't see it
the snake was sleeping it was just cool
if it was up to me it was up to me you
wanted our just left it no because
people don't understand animal behavior
so it's nighttime its coldest [ __ ] this
was a cold-blooded reptile
so it's coming in just for warmth and to
conserve energy the snake will not move
all and then when it has energy is gone
bite you yeah but it's like noon or so
wait it's noon or some sweet also so
Beach I was sleeping in this room that
was like underneath so it's like it's a
floor but then so it's the top floor and
then you go to the bottom and there's a
couple rooms there but it was right by
the first step on the bottom how did you
guys find it Meech I found it cuz he
went downstairs to get his route to his
phone and then when he looked he saw
this thing on the floor he said what the
hell is that he got like close to it
like it's my phone so he was like here
and he said holy [ __ ] that's a snake and
at first he thought it was a prank
people brought a fake snake we're not
pranksters now we'll do that we're not
like I pulled through a fake [ __ ] in his
paws oh my god that something is so big
he got close to it you're like holy [ __ ]
so he jumped I jumped over the snake
yeah down and they had to jump well
you'd get phone oh he got lucky
so he jumped but it was right by the
step so if someone would have stepped on
it on accident like yeah yes it's trying
to kick it but it was in a place where
that foam was snoring like a
[ __ ] snore [ __ ] grossest thing
ever it's not that gross oh he just
creeped me out so he's at the bottom of
the stairs right so the fire department
comes they have that stick with the
[ __ ] thing they poked it and this the
rattlesnakes like do what I'm just
trying to sleep but he was not doing
that I know it's I'm gonna [ __ ] with
Tiger I know wouldn't have to go
downstairs wait your position I don't
wanna hurt I wanna hear happen so then
they kept poking it - in hopes that make
it rise its head so that they can put
the Newton method news good news that's
pretty much an animal news it's like
this metal wire cable thing that's like
a big loop and they just and it's a
steel pole guess what they put it over
the head and then they ain't gets we
could grab the head okay yeah yeah kept
trying to do that and they kept poking
it to lift its head up and this fools
like come on stop guys so he went in the
carotid a small crack between the wall
that was on the floor and between the
wall had a crack so he went right back
into the wall but if he just had a break
up
he's like I'm stopped broken how big was
it five feet Oh
it's all like you how thick was it I
don't know I don't know so how did they
get it out the wall we quit it so you
just went back in the wall yeah squeeze
itself in a little hole that's how crazy
it was octopus there's a fire department
stay there no so they've just plugged up
the hole and then they like looked at
all the house and try to see they're
like if you see any holes just plug
those up they were like but they are
really sensitive to heat so the
nighttime is cold they didn't have a
hole or whatever so that's my tear but
once you disturb its area that it's
kicking it out it won't come back their
way if you hear a rattle anywhere was
there a barbecue grill out there yes I
want to try to eat it what poison no but
you can eat rattlesnake but you have to
know how to destroy we have the internet
you can find anything on YouTube that's
but honestly I think people are always
way more scared of animals than they
should be so for example or other kiddos
and Boy Scouts if we would go camping
all the time sleep under the stars
that's what Steve Irwin said - he's a
crazy [ __ ] yeah he got killed by
an animal he knew these animals oh I
remember that bear documentary that guy
that like was obsessed with bears and
then he'd killed by a bear so these guys
are pushing the boundaries those guys
are pushing the boundaries if you mind
our own business like there's times when
I was a kid and we're just sleeping out
underneath the Stars and when you wake
up and you get out of your sleeping bag
there's like a bunch of scorpions like
next to your
they just want to huddle up for one but
they're not even trying to steam they
watch your body heat yes like if you
don't [ __ ] with them they're not really
gonna [ __ ] with but what have you
accidentally [ __ ] with flicker be like
if you just wash the B away he won't
stain your ass but if you're like
aggressive if we just gently walk
because most people when they see a
beetle that's me but they're not gonna
see that that gets him even more
aggressive yeah don't even wanna sting
you yeah coos that means your life is
gone if he's they don't even wanna sting
it to begin right whatever they only do
it for life or do they wanna sting me
that's some scary ass [ __ ] it looks like
they stung your butt already oh [ __ ]
Jane is your butt that be yeah I do I
love booty we're getting so many views
right now they make it look small Jane
and she wore her slimming jeans today
she know what shall I
you're freaking me out with this the
gavel doesn't want to hate you - it
doesn't want to sing yes you're being
aggressive is that the same gavel from
JK party oh no the ticket party one is
so cute he's so tiny like this yeah it
was like guilty yeah we played this game
oh yeah you guys weren't there
oh yeah you guys weren't there oh you
weren't there I was dick a party without
of me how was it going on I couldn't
tell the difference
no one was missed that's perfect Katie
we missed you're also really know it
honestly well it was really fun fun and
it's like that day so you know we filmed
icky news first and then right after I
want to go film take your party so I had
like a 12 plus hour day that day but it
didn't feel like a crazy-ass thing like
if I was working at the hospital when I
had a 12-hour shift I would be dead is
it cuz yet how long before your nurse
before no no nurse a said reprocessed
surgical instruments but um reprocess
what does I mean clean them Oh
sterilize them make sure that they're
good yes make sure there's no Dookie
grease on it nasty but yeah like I
didn't feel crazy cuz it just feels like
this doesn't feel like work yes it's
talking with friends and laughing like
my cheeks were done at the end of the
night like they were so sore that was my
first time doing a punishment video
though oh you guys have to do yeah but
we had been a wheel of punishment yeah
oh thank God I was not there I know I
was my first time I've been on JK Party
as I guess you got like a year and a
half and I have never done it you
started coming in when we stopped doing
yeah meds but then now she's officially
part of JK part
often do guys do these punishment you
should do a lock every video that's yeah
it was it was bad like PTSD from your
party you know I mean so we were in one
team and we had to eat the [ __ ]
Carolina Reaper the ghost pepper and a
jalapeno team's beard yeah
beard in my mouth big hair but what the
whole time I was like but why but why
not she was like are we gonna get a
prize at the end don't understand what
why to please the 11 year old commenter
that's what happens when I'm not there
anymore
there's just ridiculous amount of
punishments that don't make any sense I
think the worst one per face the worst
worst worst one that you do get to
experience the goodness but the worst
one was like during a Halloween one
where we had these gigantic tubs and it
was real animal organ yeah there we have
to dunk our whole body and to get it out
there were eyeballs yeah you tested oh
we were bobbing for it animal parts feed
right straight up would not do that if
you guys were like you have to I might
have to what why I don't have to do
you're not my mom
what if we pull the friend Carly don't
you to be my friend yeah be like no
peace my friends wouldn't make me do
this this crazy I was the worst one and
then like everything was greasy like why
do you guys pick this is bad I don't
know I always it I always question
myself
we don't even pick it we just were like
I don't pick it I'm fighting in a room
with like people that don't seem in my
said freaking Michael he fights me so
hard to punish I didn't he have to drink
the spit cup some bum put it under a
table and then put all the gum together
from everyone with Elijah and he had to
choose right out of that it was a
barbell guy why we all spit don't spit
in a cup all of us sorry without
throwing up cuz you threw a up thing you
didn't I'm not smelling anything yet
and nadim had a spitball so one of the
punishments was oh yeah open your mouth
and everyone they're still talking about
it we're my own squad right yeah that
was what was you it wasn't your mom so
then she has his mouth open yeah yeah I
think like that yeah and the Dean put he
puts his spit mouth he shoots it out of
a straw and land in his mouth and the
Dean was so grossed out and a Dean
through doing that's disgusting I think
you'll be great about the Sawyer I had
no idea they're like you want to be
regular JK part of like yeah JK party's
fun and then they're like yeah you got
to do all these [ __ ] weird
punishments like what what happens if
someone says no yet same usually no one
says no I will say no your your [ __ ] no
yes the wrong what it does though it
creates bonding it does it's kind of
like you know who's down you're cool I
like you think you went through some
[ __ ] together
yeah you guys are so weird you created
the traumatic event to go through
together what do you think here's the
thing though it's like once you go
through that then you can do anything in
life no post pepper a [ __ ] Carolina
Reaper and jalapeño by the time you get
to the jalapeno it tastes like a bell
pepper that's the key to success guys
punish yourselves and then you can do it
with your friends your whole trend I I
was like one time this punishment was
too weak and I was like you guys need to
shoot me with the airsoft gun on my butt
oh yeah because then whatever the
punishment was I was like nah that's not
I was like this is not right you guys
got beat when you were kids you guys are
like no snot used to a regular life no
but I felt I felt like too easy what
we're going through I had to be
honorable right I have to challenge
myself I had to do something that hurts
why do you think we're so tough now geo
and I we've been through some [ __ ] I'm
good we're tough we're so I gotta turn
on the lights on and on if you guys want
me there you know give you snacks
you know I'll hold the camera during the
punishment ones like you all put Nelson
in or put
in you guys like that will like on a
level like not boy let's eat some spicy
things and see you could take this way
did when we were little but I like
spending in each other's mouths well
that's what it upgrades to unless you I
could think of a scenario but it's
number two friends you know where the
string of the mad cheap well that's not
fun if it's for fun if you don't want to
do it you know as kids you guys never
did like like for example I could say a
bunch like eight-year-olds to go on a
small wall right oh that's an adventure
that's the same thing that's like eating
each other is bodily fluid well it gets
from there to like who's down to eat
this cockroach dude okay so do you
remember geo told me I watch big mouth
right and one of the punishments there
so big mouth is a show right where they
where they can win money probably no no
it's a cartoon on that like it talks
about puberty and stuff so one in one
episode these kids are like alright like
the older brothers are like we're gonna
play this game we're gonna put this
cracker between all of us and we're all
gonna jack off in the last person to
finish has to eat the crown that's next
level the last person to finish that's
easy I'll be the first one to finish
well these are kids like their puberty
sir like uh I don't even like five
seconds on that that's why you guys
remind me of big that that's like next
level I think like I think I'm gonna
tell Dad about that how you made me feel
right now like I was like oh uh well if
you like jackass and like I don't know
there's like this level of guys I feel
like that would be scared are you with
the blood day
exactly they just growth clippers and
they just go and that's the transition
for their movie that's not even a real
punishment can you guys imagine walking
around random balls
I'd always be like so Tommy just like
Bam Margera's parents they're [ __ ]
crazy yeah like they're both poor people
they're like forever they're getting
pray for their son like even went in the
middle of the night they're sleeping
[ __ ] you would just jump in and start
[ __ ] them up yeah and then the uncle
to the chunk now they're like they're
like holy beings mmm like Jesus and
laughter holy beings about Bam Margera
yeah but but look at how much money he
made for his parents he's missing up
front tooth and [ __ ] though no he didn't
he didn't make all that money through
that it was initially hue as a pro
skateboarder and then he got into that
yeah but in between his skate videos he
would do those things right like he
would career accord those right and then
so that became more popular than him
skate yeah but then he he actually
started making a lot of money and then
he can take care of his parents and all
that but it was just like that's just
from unhealthy eating that too but yeah
so you're from Michael yeah see that a
lot otherwise I'm impressed
wait you're born and raised there no I
was born here in Bellflower California
oh really and then I went over there
went yeah love think really yeah I don't
think I do it is the shoot pool they're
real hard times yeah all right I was
born there I didn't really grow up there
so I grew up in town on Mako Island
Marchese I was over there I was 13 and
then I came over here when I was 13
I'm on Broadus and then I've left here
ever since so 13 years so you didn't
speak any English when you're out I was
really hard and the people made fun of
me or the kids at school make fun of me
you guys this is like traumatizing us
[ __ ] what do they make for them because
I couldn't say the difference between
tree like a tree 3 yeah ok ok what's 2
plus 1 I really
no I didn't know I don't know how to say
that bad but I was just like good me
thanks yeah I mean it was really harder
than these girls were always trying to
fight me when I was well but it's funny
cuz you're in a Mexican neighborhood so
it's Mexican kids making fun of you okay
so there's a difference between like
poor choice which is like I guess now
I'm gonna put Chuck cuz you know it's
more here for sure yeah so like it's
kids who have Mexican parents but grew
up here you know what I mean so they
make hella fun like us and Fox yeah yeah
yeah yeah dude like oh yeah my sister's
well nobody know yeah that's the good
said oh really like a 20 like they would
call me Paisano at the warehouse and you
feel like you fit in I didn't even know
what that meant a paisa buy somebody's
like homie you know I mean like eight
homey
yeah but if somebody calls too I mean if
somebody called me a paisa I was like oh
yeah that's you know what it depends on
how you use it if I call her paisa like
it's like that's my oh my sauna you know
they also call me chinito gomez oh
that's why you created that character no
um no no Charlie no Charlie no Gomez
they would call me Carlos Sanchez no I
think it's I'm mixing your character
chinito Gomez okay
yeah yeah no Charlie no okay yeah yeah
no because we would they would play the
music all the time and I'm like who is
that I like this guy
really and I was like oh it's chilly no
ciolino and I was like okay and then
they just kept calling me that or
Paisano or paisa do you ever them I
think so then I recognize all the time
with dancing and I write banda you do
i'm songwriter my life between all
you're on their talent yep
[Music]